[Applause]
sorry
and if you'll kindly take your seats
and so without any further ado I'd like
to introduce dr. Joanne Murphy director
of the William J Clinton Leadership
Institute to begin proceedings good
evening everybody my name is Joanne
Murphy and it is my great pleasure to
welcome you to the third William J
Clinton leadership lecture as you know
President Clinton gave his name to our
Institute which is a part of Queens
management school and I'm privileged to
be as interim director within the wider
structure of the school this leadership
lecture has previously been delivered by
Bill Clinton himself and also FW de
Klerk and we are delighted to have
Michelle Barnea here this evening to
carry on that extraordinary legacy Bill
Clinton spoke about the need to build
bridges to the future the convention
Institute was established to build
leadership capacity in this region on
these islands and beyond building
bridges to new economies new sectors and
new opportunities you're all here
because you're leaders in one way or
another we in the Institute exists to
support you and those who will follow
you in your diverse and your exciting
leadership journeys we work from the
principle of evidence-based
decision-making and the power of
research and inquiry giving you access
to world-class research here at Queens
and through our international
partnerships our focus is on building
strong impactful and diverse strategic
partnerships with business government
and society and we are delighted to see
so many of our partners here in this
room this evening I would like I would
invite you to take some time later this
evening to explore the information
provided in the brochures on your chairs
myself and my colleagues would be
delighted to speak to you further about
our plans for the future and the work
that we will continue today within the
clinton institute now I have the great
pleasure of introducing our prayers
and Vice Chancellor Professor Ian Greer
so ladies and gentlemen can I add my
welcome to that of Juwan it's great to
see so many of you here in Queens
tonight for this lecture I'd like to
offer a very warm welcome to our guest
speaker Michel Barnier in advance of his
Clinton leadership lecture reflections
on brexit and the European Union now I
should say that's not about colleagues
from the assembly have been delayed at
Stormont today as they mark the passing
of Seamus Mullen but they do hope to
join us later now Joanne has told you a
little bit about the Clinton Leadership
Institute it's work as part of the
management school here at Queens and it
has been a real difference to many
organizations by developing its
strategic leadership capacity but
arguably one of the greatest challenges
to leadership in the present day and
these islands at least its brakes so
tonight's lecture is timely not least
because we're on the cusp of breaks at
31st of January just in case she'd
forgotten and at that point the UK and
EU embarked on a transition period with
negotiations focused on a new trade deal
Queens like other universities has
numerous challenges arising from braixen
however I'd like to recast them as major
opportunities to make a difference
opportunities to lead and develop new
initiatives and I guess there are three
main areas that we'd like to focus on
we'd like to continue to drive you to
pian an international research
collaboration which has been so well
supported by European funding we'd like
to look at new approaches to start and
student mobility which is absolutely
critical in our sector as we want to
drive knowledge economies and here in
the island of Ireland we'll get specific
opportunities where I think working
across this island could make a real
difference in health and cybersecurity
and agri-food and sustainability the
challenges we face across Ireland are
the same so we should work together so
it's critical that we have a strong
relationship with the Republic of
Ireland who have been making a massive
investment and to research the
innovation and into their higher
education system and
investment of over two billion euros to
make a real difference universities make
a real difference to the economies here
in Queens we deliver 1.9 billion pounds
per year of economic impact to the UK
and we're not exceptional many
universities will deliver that type of
performance so we are crucial to driving
the economy forward and that's important
as we embark on this new journey that we
think about how we develop and fund
place-based initiatives that can drive
forward the economies on both sides of
the border on this island and of course
east and west also to take advantages of
the UK's industrial strategy where
Northern Ireland can play a real role so
what's these challenges that will be
invaluable to have the perspective of
our guest speaker Michel Barnier he's
become very well known in these islands
over the past few years a few years as
European chief negotiator for the UK
exiting the EU and now as head of the
task force for relations with the UK and
I guess it's no surprise that he was
given these roles and view of his
experience a career spanning almost 50
years with both French national and
European politics starting I think at
age 27 when he became a member of the
French National Assembly serving on
several French cabinets with ministerial
positions including Minister for Foreign
Affairs a European Commission of us
responsibility for regional policy and
institutional reform and 2009 after
being elected an MEP he was appointed
European Commissioner for internal
markets and services and he handled many
important areas for the financial sector
a forum the banking union union and a
digital single market so when the
president of the European Commission
jean-claude Juncker wanted an
experienced politician for the statical
job referring to brexit Michel Barnier
was perhaps the obvious choice and now
that the UK's position is cleared he can
turn his sights on future relations
between the EU and the UK so we're
really grateful to you for taking the
time to come and talk to this evening
and we look forward to hearing you so
please join him in welcome
our guest speaker Michele Barney
[Applause]
the design judgment or distinguished
guests vice-chancellor professor Yana
Greer thank you very much for your kind
words it's true that I have been the
youngest member of the French National
Assembly it's a title you lose very
quickly and you have to be humble it is
a real pleasure to be in Queen's
University Belfast this evening
real pleasure and it is an honor to
deliver the William Clinton leadership
lecture I know it is a sad day to follow
us on Ireland today and my thoughts with
the family and friends of Seamus Mullen
he played a fundamental role in the
peace process he was one of the
architects of the Good Friday Belfast
agreements the German Queen's University
shares its motto with the city of
Belfast proton talk with EDB bubbles for
so much we what shall we give in return
this captures the societal
responsibility of your University your
dedication to cutting-edge research with
the testimony to that motto and here
researchers like dr. John Murphy
professor Richard English and many
others addressed some of the world's
biggest societal challenges food
security council cybercrime terrorism
and conflict and brexit researchers such
as dr. Katie a world of Professor David
Fenimore has made an important important
contribution to the debate in Northern
Ireland
in Westminster and beyond thanks to you
Dawson Islands unique political social
and economic reality is understood more
broadly so far so much
what shall will be given in return
anyone who old public office should
reflect on this question including
myself
the you chief negotiator for new
partnership with the United Kingdom this
attachment over the last three years
have had the privilege of working with a
exceptional team together we enjoyed the
trust the former Commission President
jean-claude Juncker and now the new
president is lavender Lane
the former Council President Donald Tusk
and now Shar Michele 227 United member
states the United government and the
European Parliament which first must
ensure and you Tonto new attorney and
now Dave it's a story with such trust
comes a great responsibility the
responsibility to work hand-in-hand with
the elected representatives in European
Parliament the EU leaders in the
European Council ministers and member of
national parliaments in the member
states the responsibility to clearly
explain our positions to all those
affected the responsibility to ensure
the higher level of transparency perhaps
an unusual level of transparency in this
negotiation the responsibility to engage
respectfully respectfully with UK
negotiators who represent a great nation
one which has been part of the you for
47 years we have always stuck and we
will always stick to this line
no aggressiveness no punishment no
spirit of revenge no frustration or
impatience but the House of Commons was
unable to agree on what kind of breaks
it
it wanted we have always respected the
ongoing debate in the UK and we will
continue to do so lastly we had and we
still have the responsibility to
encourage genuine public debate and
breaks it and how it affects you and the
UK in particular Island and North Island
and frankly speaking this debate that
always been easy just look at my Twitter
account
but it is important people must be aware
of the consequences because ladies and
gentlemen it is absolutely clear that
there will be negative consequences the
UK Chancellor side Javits recognized
last week that part of Industry will
face the negative for out what whatever
agreement we reach on our future
relationship brexit will always be a
matter of damage limitation always and
no one single person no one from the UK
or elsewhere has ever convinced me of
the added value of bracket no.1 at least
with the wisdom agreement which has now
been ratified by the UK and we will be
agreed by the European Parliament I hope
next week or this week sorry and
Wednesday we have managed to secure an
orderly breaks it for now one that
limits the description of value for our
citizens and businesses and this is also
our objective going forward I am once
again pleased to be in Northern Ireland
to explain where we stand in the process
and our position going forward but also
to listen and engage this is the designs
run my third visit to North Island in my
current role have been to the border on
above times I walk on the Peace Bridge
in Derry Londonderry I have engaged with
politicians of all parties students
businesses owners and I am sure that the
Northern Ireland rural women's network
in
dan Gannon remember us how moved I was
by my meeting with them and I talk about
it very often because brexit is first
and foremost about people and I can
still remember their words never again
never again a gentleman the European
Union has always been a peace project
and we are reminded of that today an
auto cost Memorial Day
after years of devastating war and
conflict European integration
transformed the meaning of national
borders the genius of the founding
phasors the you was to focus an open
trade and economic exchange as an
element of peace not just prosperity
this was true for France and Germany in
the 1915 it were all through and also
true when the Berlin Wall and the iron
curtain came down the you gradually
became a community of 28 countries
reuniting the continent and breaking
down borders today people goods services
and capital can circulate freely from
one member state to another this is the
single market and the single market
ladies and gentlemen is much more much
more than a free trade zone it is an
ecosystem an ecosystem that Europeans
built together everyday with common laws
and regulations common rights and
standards for work
and consumers come in stand out from the
environment coming supervisions
mechanism and on top of this a commander
addiction the Court of Justice of the
European Union it is an ecosystem that
UK contributed to for 47 years
an ecosystem that builds trust between
countries and with it
prosperity fairness and most importantly
peace and once again the UK contributed
a lot to this achievements and it
benefited or anonymously for the single
market that it perhaps why brexit came
as such a shock to so many in June 2016
52% of the people of the United Kingdom
voted to leave to your opinion indeed
considerably less here in Northern
Ireland at 45 for persons but the
direction that took place in December
last year confirmed the dookey
government's mandate to get brexit done
and so the UK will leave you in just
four days
I do not forget this data
the gentleman breaks it is meant to be
about taking back control but what else
does it mean it means creating trade
barriers that do not exist today the
decision to stop free movement means
stopping citizens from moving freely
between the U and the UK to study work
or retry practice is about diverging for
EU rules rules developed together with
the UK once again that protect the
public interest guarantee open and fair
competition and thereby a low
frictionless trade brexit is also meant
to be about global Britain but for us
frankly speaking it is the U that helps
make member states more global even
without the UK do you form the single
market of four hundred and fifty million
people the truly global market our
economic power allows us to stand
proudly proudly on the world stage to
speak with other superpowers as equals
on questions such as the economy climate
change security and trade there is no
way there is no way that any of our
countries alone could have the same
impact especially as author Academy
Giants emerge around the world
let me just now show you two simple
slides two tables the first one
as a particular history because it has
been published for the first time by
David Cameron I would at that time the
Commissioner in charge the single market
and to prove the importance the single
market for the UK he published a
document to support what I was doing not
on the regulation not on the financial
services but on Sigler market and the
slide is very clear by 2050 no
individual European countries can expect
to be among the global top 5 economies
in the world that the UK not even
Germany and the second one is my
prediction is clear also using the same
figures together the you 27
will remain in the top four
just a few days ago Chancellor Merkel
compared you to life insurance for our
country she recognized that in today's
global environment and I quote Germany
is far too small to exert geopolitical
influence on its own for that she said
it needs the single market this is why
our single market is so crucial to us
and it is why there will be no
compromise on the single market for us
and yet in the UK it seems that many
still believe that they can leave the
you institutions leave the biggest
trading bloc in the world depart from
regulations that they helped to put in
place without experiencing any negative
side-effects ladies and gentlemen
Northern Ireland will be the part of the
UK most impacted by brexit while
Northern Ireland as a specific
constitutional and legal set up both in
terms of governance and in terms of
cooperation with Island the Good Friday
Belfast agreement set up specific cross
community power sharing governance
structures here in Northern Ireland
thanks to that people like David Trimble
genuine and of course Seamus Mullen
Martin McGuinness and Ian Paisley could
find solutions to accommodate the
different identities and competing
political views across Northern Ireland
this work needed political courage and
artwork from politicians across Northern
Ireland
they managed which add of the Irish and
British governments and notably Bertie
Erin thank you to be here tonight
Anthony Blair let's not forget the role
of others like Bill Clinton George
Mitchell or Alaric inton this
University's new chancellor the Good
Friday Belfast agreement was and still
is indispensable for progress the Good
Friday Belfast agreement allowed and
still allows the people of Northern
Ireland to identify themselves as
British or Irish or both and be accepted
as such so you can choose to be British
Irish very British with a bit of Irish
more Irish than British Irish and
European British and European other
might think I'm Jen Selter
no Solaris or Northern Irish and
European are indeed Northern Irish and
Aunty European this multitude of
identities is a distinctive aspect of
Northern Ireland
similarly Stormin is not based on the
rule of the majority but on the power
sharing and compromise and ancestral
element of building peace and indeed
frankly speaking once again we missed
Stormont during the negotiation on
brexit and Northern Ireland although I
met with northern islands leader many
times many times in the last few years
the requests were always to meet
separately with one party never to meet
together and this afternoon I met with
Sinn Fein's Deputy First Minister mr.
O'Neil together together with GP economy
mr. diam dots representing the First
Minister Alan Foster so I'm very glad to
see the Legislative Assembly restored
finally I think it's fair to say that
the fact that both Ireland and UK where
member of the you were also very
important in bringing stability to the
end violent because they shared the same
rules and add a common trade policy
companies could trade in a frictionless
way without checks or custom procedures
the gentleman very early on in the
withdrawal negotiations both the UN UK
acknowledged
that the situation in Masan island was
unique and that it required a specific
solution a solution that was legally
operative and could reconcile the many
different interests at play in
particular avoiding a border between
Ireland and Northern Ireland and
preserving the Overland economy in the
rest of peace and security but also
preserving the integrity of the youth
single market and all its guarantees for
consumer protection public and animal
earth and finally respecting the place
of narsil island as an integral part of
the United Kingdom's
internal market of course finding common
ground was not easy I can tell you but
the U was tireless in its efforts we
listened to Irish concerns to Northern
Irish and British concerns we mapped out
north-south cooperation with the UK we
investigated different options we went
back to the drawing table various times
to design new measures or to reassure
with Prime Minister Theresa May we had
found an agreement on the UK wide
backstop this meant the rule of the UK
forming a single customs territory with
EU unless and until but unless and until
a better solution could be found many
people in Northern Ireland acknowledged
the benefits of having a backstop but
there were also fears in Westminster
that the UK could get trapped in a
custom union with you for an indefinite
period of time without its
trade policy and despite reassurances
that Wien strain in low press Minister
was not convinced that the you has no
intention of acting in that phase so in
summer 2019 the Prime Minister Board
Johnson asked us to abandon the backstop
they wanted a terminal solution not a
temporary one one that enables the UK to
deploy is own independent trade policy
immediately after the transition period
and again and again we showed
flexibility and understanding and we
found an agreement also with the
presence report of the tea shock
liova rajagaha the gentlemen the
protocol on Ireland and Northern Ireland
that we have agreed indeed is complex
that operational it allows Northern
Ireland to remain in the UK customs
territory and at the same time benefit
from access to the single market without
tariffs Coty's checks or control the
protocol is not an insurance policy but
a workable system built to last and
importantly it gives to elected
representatives the Northern Ireland's
Legislative Assembly the right to decide
whether to continue applying the system
or not four years after it starts to
apply I look forward to the Northern
Ireland's executive playing a stronger
role on this matter now that it's up and
running
implementing this new system will be a
big challenge for the next few weeks and
months
in particular for UK authorities in
agreeing to the protocol the UK has
agreed to a system of reinforced check
and control for goods entering Northern
Ireland from Great Britain I understand
the design gentlemen understand the fear
of negative economic fall out expressed
by some about these checks but once
again breaks it unfortunately as
consequences that we must manage the UK
has chosen to become a third country to
leave the single market and to leave
this custom unions to leave behind the
UK the youth the youth framework of
common rules command supervision and
common Court of Justice yes
chosen to create two regulatory space
this makes frictionless trade impossible
it makes checks indispensable we will
need sanitary and phytosanitary checks
on food products and live animals you
must be able to assess risks on any
products coming into its market and if
necessary
activate physical controls the checks
must take place somewhere and the whole
point of the protocol is to avoid at
border and protect or idle economy it
was clear clear that the could not take
place at the land border between Ireland
and Northern Ireland the only real
option was to use Northern Ireland's
other entry points this is also where
such checks are the easiest the easiest
to implement and control will also take
place in Dublin and in the other EU and
three parts this is a German it's now
the U and the UK's joint responsibility
joint responsibility to make this
Agreement work on the
you take this responsibility very
seriously and let's be clear we have
been creative we have been flexible in
finding a workable solution but it is a
detailed legal text it is a legal
detailed legal text now it's time to
implement it precisely the wisdom
agreement must be applied with rigor and
discipline by all sides
it cannot be reopened under the guise of
implementation we will be monitoring its
correct application very carefully this
is also true of the other crucial
element covered in the winter Agreement
namely citizens rights
wines northern northern island will no
longer party you people born and raised
here that choose to be Irish citizens
will still be EU citizens this means
they can continue to move and reside
freely within the you the UK has
committed to upholding the rights and
they cannot be discriminated against on
the basis of nationality the wisdom
agreement will also protect the rights
of all British nationals living in the
you and their family for life the
Commission will make sure that each and
every one of the 27 member states live
up to their commitment but we will also
be watching closely to make sure that
the UK government does the same for the
more than 3 million EU citizens residing
in the UK
I've already raised the issue with
Stefan Barclay the UK Secretary of State
for exciting the you and we will
continue to be particularly vigilant to
this in particular to the set up of the
independent monitoring authority this
body must be truly independent and deal
effectively with complaints from Union
citizens and their families the dessert
round EU will never return it's back to
its citizens never and you will not turn
its back on Northern Ireland even at
leave the Union
never the peace funding program which
since 1995 and which I was myself
responsible has the Commission of
regional policy supports peace and
reconciliation and promote economic and
social progress in Northern Ireland and
the border region of Ireland this
program will continue this is sign of
our commitment to peace and stability
here you can continue to count on our
support the gentleman with the red women
setters all aspects of the UK's divorce
from the he also provides us with at
least 11 months of continuity we will
need this time to implement all the
points I've just mentioned but we also
need this time and probably more to
build a new partnership because the
reality is that we have to rebuild
everything everything the UK I just
mentioned this morning in the brain that
living the youth single market and the
custom new means for the UK to live
mechanically automatically 600
international agreements 600 so we have
to rebuild everything
and we will rebuild everything
negotiating the future partnership
between the US UK is so another huge
challenge a new clock is ticking 11
months is extremely short Prime Minister
Johnson has said he will not extend this
period
this means that UK will leave the single
market and the customs union at the end
of this year this is a UK choice not our
choice but we respect it and we will do
everything we can in the short time that
it's make available never never will it
be you that fails uncommon ambition
never but this is clearly a unique
situation since its inception the U has
been in the business of removing borders
not create example our aim has been to
bring Europeans closer to each other
students researchers professionals
employees entrepreneurs pensioners now
the UK wants a stricter migration policy
that may apply to you a non EU national
like possibly as early as 2021 similarly
when we negotiate with third country our
aim is usually to remove barriers to
trade we do this by aligning standards
and regulations the you are even become
so good at this that many of its
standards many of these relations have
become the gold standard internationally
our regulatory influence goes well
beyond our borders
because of the size of our single market
and our high standards that the reason
why our trade and investment partners
trust us they are cool
our competitive edge aligning with our
standards may have a price but the
return is access to our single market
our status that is testified the quality
and safety of our products and services
whether it's an EU logo or toy or a
geographical indication for agricultural
products but there are also a testimony
to our dedication to continuously
improving working rights to raising
environmental standards and leading the
fight against climate change to fight in
tax fraud and diversion and to ensuring
fair and open competition in our up
joint political declaration on our
future relationship the UK agreed that
we need common standards to avoid unfair
competitive advantage so when it tell us
he does not want to align with EU
standards and regulation in the future
it is not clear to me not clear for the
moment well or by how much it wishes to
diverge on standards relating to the
safety and quality of products or on
those relating to fair competitions it's
not clear to me not yet whether when the
UK leaves the u unethical market it will
also choose to live Europe's receta
societal societal and regulatory model
that is the Queen Turkey questions and
we are waiting for an answer because
that answer during this negotiation will
be key for our future relationship and
to be frank ladies and gentlemen I hope
that our UK friends
are reflecting carefully carefully on
this issue and on this answer because UK
cannot accept high quality access to our
single market if expect equality access
for a single market if it's insist on
competing unstated
policy social and environmental
standards
I will not want to be misunderstood
competition between our economies is not
a bad thing countries compete with each
other also within the single market but
competition needs to be based on common
eye level of standards to make sure it
is fair
once again the UK is faced with a choice
our ambition the EU's ambition is to
create a close economic partnership one
that is based on a level playing field
that is the only way we will be able to
achieve truly ambitious deal a deal that
benefits both sides a deal that is fair
for our workers our taxpayers businesses
and for the planet a deal that even if
it will never match what we have now
lives up to our ambition to remain the
best of friends and allies and of course
and ambitious partnership to be frank
cannot be limited to trade
that must also cover many Shu and many
challenges on internal and external
security and obviously defense security
the stability of the continent the
gentlemen it's clear that the
negotiations the future EU Juke a resin
ship will be a prominent focus in 2020
but this will not be on our side and our
only horizon we will continue to work on
strengthening the you together at 27 we
will continue working to protect our
citizens and to equip them to deal with
the challenges of our time among others
this will involve number one an
ambitious new green deal that will help
to reconcile our economy with the planet
and turned you into the world's first
climate neutral continent by 2050 number
two we will also do more to support
Europe's most vulnerable and as we
transition to a clean and digital
economy number three we will increase
funding for Erasmus so that more
residents and the opportunity to live
study or work in another EU Member
States we know that education research
can be a game-changer in tackling some
of our biggest societal challenges up
front
number four we will step up our efforts
to protect our external borders number
five we will deep and cross-border
cooperation on security including very
possible with the UK as a third country
to tackle gaps in the fight against
serious crimes and terrorism terrorism
in Europe this is are just some of the
priority that new presentation use
lavender lion will take forward in the
next
five years these are the issues that you
will focus on added strives to deliver
more for its citizens the gentleman for
so much
what will we give in return we did not
create the opinion we inherited it from
our parents and grandparents it has
brought us peace opportunities Regional
Development and a better understanding
of each other it is now our
responsibility to take this project
forward to improve it and when necessary
to change it to equip it for the next
generations on the 1st of February four
days from now four days the 20 new
member state will open a new chapter of
their history they will continue
dismantling barriers between themselves
they will do so without the UK but we
will be willing to build a close
partnership with the country which will
remain our partner Ally our friend in
Luke so we will never lose sight of the
unique situation of the island of
Ireland and finally we will continue to
engage as widely as possible in a spirit
of openness and respect
allow me to finish on a more personal
note for many reasons I'll reread brexit
and I sometimes recall that my very
first vote as a young French citizen I
was 21 it was in 72 you can just know my
age now
the French president reported organized
a referendum and our French people to
decide themselves about the accession of
Island UK Denmark and Norway and despite
the fact I was and still am map of the
goriest party in my country I campaign
for the yes I campaigned for the
accession of Duke a and I never never
regret this vote and this campaign I
will always continue to believe that we
are better off together than alone
especially especially in today's world
that is why I will remain a patriot from
my country and European at the same time
but I will also always have profound
respect for the UK its people its
culture it's great leaders and its
solidarity with the rest of Europe
during the darkest hours that is why at
the beginning of this new chapter for
European history of this new journey I
would really I would sincerely like to
wish the UK well so thank you for giving
me the opportunity to do so here in
Northern Ireland tonight thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much indeed for that
wonderful talk we have a short period of
time for some questions and mr. Bernier
has kindly said that he will take some
questions during the next session there
were going to be microphones which will
enable the questioner to be heard so
who'll start for us
now okay there's a question there at the
back the microphone can go with a lady
at the back just wait for the microphone
to come thank you lady with the blonde
hair back
bring with Leah Fragger that to me who
you are
oh sorry I'm Debra my police from you TV
trumpet evening report
do you agree with Lee over Edgar that
the EU will be will be the stronger team
a post breaks into tree talks and do you
have concerns about Northern Ireland's
economic future
I'm sure that you as a strong team yes
true
but I remember that once in Brazil at
that time I gave a press conference you
press form of the euro Commission and
one of your colleagues of BBC remember
asked me
Shivani can you explain us what
coefficient you are ready to give just
I don't know polar can can explain to us
what without the concession you are
ready to to give to the UK tourney's
negotiations it was two years ago and my
answer was clear I'm not ready and
nothing the the thing to ask concession
to the European to give confidence to
the UK this is an extra gene in
negotiation unusual negotiations did UK
decided to leave it's not our choice we
are not leaving the UK the UK leaving
the U so we have to find that the best
compromise for the elderly breaks it and
my goal I wish my work was dedicated
live for the last few years to find the
way to organize this divorce in the
orderly manner now we are in the second
state because everything must be rebuilt
I think this point must be clear we have
to repeat everything and the UK and its
side will have to repeat everything with
so many third countries and partners in
the world but for us with the UK we have
to rebuild everything and to secure
everything for the future in new
agreements so not willing to ask
concession to the UK or to give
concessions we have to define the both
balance balance balance the most
balanced agreement for the future
relations so I forward to the second
point
yes I've concerned because it was the
marquee point of them my speech
perhaps I can begin again to I will give
my speech by later just for you to read
it tonight or the sweetness we can no no
I still have concerns because I still
have concerns first of all for the peace
I know the piece is fragile
it's a reason why when I was in that
Gannon or some other place I understand
clearly that the key point is about
people much more than world trade or or
or economy it's about people and my suit
where day and night about the peace in
our working for this with red women and
now I think that compromise we found
with our gentleness is good for our
survival which is by profound collection
and we have to implement this complex
but workable operational agreement in
the best ways possible so we have to
work to to put all the to put in place
the implementation of this this with the
agreement that this Harris protocol in
the best way as possible and I will do
my best for the economy and the
stability of now around thank you
there's a questionnaire at the back yes
the microphones that finally BBC
Northern Ireland mr. Varney I can assure
you that we all did listen very
carefully to your speech but despite all
that you've already said is there any
potential deal which might be done by
the end of the transition period the end
of the
which might avoid which might prevent
check some Goods moving from Great
Britain here to Northern Ireland is
there anything possible the text is not
precise though I always tell the truth
to everybody and I we have to implement
this treaty it is an international
treaty a legal treaty binding treaty for
both sides and we will implement is
still in all its dimensions so you know
that there is a Joint Committee we have
to work the Joint Committee but we will
work that my twenties we tried during
this negotiation with Theresa May first
and now after with Boris Johnson to
square the cycle if I miss a square
cycle Pristina island definitely Ohio
economy which is linked protecting the
integrity of single market that means
protecting the you consumers and the new
businesses and number three the before
for the northern island Tara to be part
of the custom territory of the UK it is
four parts and in the middle that means
no border so we we have to find we found
to do the way to square cycle so that
without the UK with the UK we did the
government of London and now I just want
to say that we have to make sure that
this Irish protocol will works and I'm
sure that if it's works thanks to this
report everybody
it will be good for Nelson Island I'm
sure that thank you there's another
question at the back that the microphone
go to the planner
thank you very much
oh hello miss ends - Bonnie Amanda
Ferguson from Reuters news agency my
concern to you that Prime Minister Boris
Johnson continues to insist that
there'll be no checks whatsoever between
Northern Ireland and the rest of the UK
after asking the question I know what is
written in this text which is once
against an international treaty ratified
by the House of Commons in the next few
days ratified the European Parliament
and we have to respect this text in all
its dimensions thank you there's a
question at the back on the left hand
side right at the end there I'm going
any order people so this is good
microphone go over to them I left there
but no the next person it was before you
just there at the end thank you very
much thank you from Amanda's question
recognizing that the Prime Minister has
stated emphatically and which means
without doubt that the be unfettered
access it's both ways and I hear in your
speech you're saying it emphatically
without doubt that there will not be
friction strained between Britain and
their environment I'm a quick estimate
and what are the consequences of not
fully implemented
thank you I just say that living the you
living single market living the say the
community did shots at UK will have
consequences and what I saw in passed in
the last few that many of these
consequences that has been
underestimated in the UK side or not so
well explained to the people so now we
we have to to face a reality and to be
realistic
there will be no possibility for
friction let trade between you and the
UK after the breaks it at least we will
have control on goods because we have
the duty the responsibility to protect
the EU consumers and you businesses the
color of the single market built with
the UK during 47 years having the
commission of the single market for five
years during the identity crisis and we
have rebuilt with the UK the
architecture of regulation to draw the
lessons of the financial crisis but
there will be no compromise on the
single mark never never never
it is our main asset and you side the
main reason why the American president
of the Chinese present respect us today
it is you can rocket will now next week
the end of this year for and 400 million
and 50 million hundred and fifty million
consumer and citizens and 22 billion 13
to millions businesses it is our main
asset never the you will compromise
fragile I'll unravel the signal market
never and you have to take into account
is this reality to to get the
explanation or the reason why we
conclude such an agreement
Boris Johnson and now my I wish my wish
if I may say after the third question at
the same point is to ask you will
meditate to use your energy and to ask
the leaders and to ever be to you the
energy to implement this agreement as it
is and we are ready to be a realistic to
be flexible to be to be a pragmatic I
will patent private person despite the
fact I am French I ask you to understand
that we have to implement this agreement
which is a key point for the stability
of this island and also for the
credibility and the trust we must give
to this withdraw agreement and to be
frank the capacity we must have together
you can us to implement good face and
carefully and rigorously this agreement
will be very useful for the success of
the next negotiation thank you there's
another question at the back on the left
and then do a couple of questions at the
front but to take the one the back of
the microphone come yes please thanks
very much I don't see you unfortunately
because of the light
I'm a Blouin and I'm asking a question
that goes away from the last questions
so you mentioned that the agreement is
very good for Northern Ireland and I've
seen some illegal blocks especially from
Germany saying it's a little bit too
good for our island
so the truce can be in the middle money
that the agreement should be challenged
before the European Court of Justice 1
because it actually gives up the
indivisibility of the internal market I
do not think that's correct because
Northern Ireland is always a hybrid and
it will be in a hybrid situation and it
will be outside of the EU and secondly
it says that because of it's so good for
Northern Ireland there will be detriment
for citizens and other new countries and
they should challenge that agreement do
you see any legal resident we were
equipped to build this treaty this is
not a speech is that a declaration this
treaty is a treaty a legal text and we
were caught with the legal service of
the European Council the council and
obviously the little service of the
Commission which is a very respected and
credible legal service so we took all
the precautions and I hope it will work
so I see the truce in the middle and
signets this agreement is will be good
for Northern Ireland and will be good
and necessary for the stability of the
island but I think that we have at the
same time it is original by my three
previous answers the same time we have
to give the insurance the Member States
to the businesses to the consumers that
the integrity of the single market will
be protected it is a point and everybody
here and outside has to understand that
we have to protect the single market
sometimes it seems to be curious that
some in the UK because you can't beat
the supermarket whizzers I can tell you
with a high degree of influence very
high degree here sometimes it seems to
be very courage that sums does not
understand why we want to protect this
Eagle market and we will do thank you
there was the question from a gentleman
down here at the front if the microphone
could come around let's put your hand up
again with you thank you that's great
thanks very much I thank you michelle
varney a Richard Ramsay Ulster Bank
clearly the brexit vote was a shock to
the EU maybe too many of us and the UK
you mentioned the brexit you regret
practices and practices like damage
limitation with that in mind looking
back to the concessions which were
offered to David Cameron is there
anything that you think now with
hindsight maybe an extra concession that
you should have given and if so what was
thank you
I am a politician
I'm not a super technocratic process
also as a politician I never worked with
nostalgia
I can rewrite we cannot rewrite history
here thank you just one here these guys
these guys very patient so it breaks it
this is growth patience young guy
there's these questions will have to be
lost so there's a gentleman the white
and then there's the patient man in the
middle say thanks very much yep that's
right
thank you thanks hi you can call me the
director of the northern Retail
Consortium and over the past 30 years
one of the very few good things that has
come from this process as they a might
of access and their mind of
conversations that the business
community in Northern Ireland has had
with the EU with the Commission and with
your task force as well in fact they
phase agreement within mayor's day and
the qualified persons agreement within
the mayor's date was because we asked
those questions and you delivered on
them my question is can you give us a
firm commitment today that going through
to Phase two and when it comes phase
three of these negotiations that you
will commit to continuing the lesson to
the Northern Ireland business voice
under the voice of Northern Ireland high
schools as well yes
it's it's always great when you get
crisp questions but even better when you
get crisp answers so thank you this is
all going to be our final question so
thank you my name is karma card I have a
master's student here at Queens and he
spoke eloquently my Shivani about the
peace process and I was born 97 so why
thankfully like thousands of young
people already grew up with no knowledge
of the troubles and expectation and a
hope for the future
brexit puts a lot of that into doubt
there's a lot of worry for the thousands
of young people at this university and
all across Northern Ireland I just
wonder what is your message to the young
people four days out from brexit what is
your message to young people in northern
art you have the power to express your
views you have the power to to vote now
in the future you have the power to to
change
and nobody can prevent you to remain
European in addition to be a citizen of
Nationale nobody thank you we've had a
wonderful evening three words of thanks
before we close first thanks to all of
you for taking time out of your busy
schedules to be here for this important
event second thank you to the William
Jay Clinton Leadership Institute and
then we have to commit to that because
that's the schedule so but mainly can he
please show a very warm appreciation for
Michel van Gogh
[Applause]
you
[Music]